oh that's a question you feel brave
enough
why not
you're stupid enough
[Laughter]
go on
wait who said it no i i said it i said
oh okay
if you're stupid enough then yeah go for
it like but no not more so than anything
date who you want more so you just
understand that there are consequences
for dating
women that have chosen to make those
decisions and if you're able to live
with the consequences
kudos to you but more so you should
understand that you won't like the
repercussions of what
is going to come out of that i guess it
depends on if they've healed or not yeah
like
absolutely
they probably i was just about to say
you can have a bad boy face because
you're going through something maybe
you're young you've got issues
people mature people grow when women
grow they change
yeah but the problem is
this is this is the issue that a lot of
men find themselves in is the girls
really wanted the bad boys
they just accepted the the nice guy
because they couldn't lock the bad boy
down
and really
that's who they want to be with
is it
or is it just
maybe you have trauma and this person
that treats you like [ __ ] you're like oh
i'm so attracted to him but it's because
your father was disapproving of you and
so you want this person that rejects you
that's a very specific
i mean i don't know
well i think women are attracted to
traits like they call it the dark triad
trait so women are attracted to traits
that are like negative about guys
because they're also positive like the
guy like why why why do we date guys
that punch holes in the wall
it's because the same guy that is super
aggressive like maybe towards us and
just in general can also protect us
yeah okay so yeah yeah so it's like a
double the same guy that treats you like
[ __ ] it shows that he thinks highly of
himself because he can stand up for
himself
okay
and so what a lot of guys finally said
20 to 25 of marriages are sexless
and typically it's the woman holding out
like guys want to have sex
yeah but is that because she's repressed
because women are either demonized for
being
sexual or they're taught
hydrosexuality you need to be more than
that right i think they're first in
their marriage yeah yeah but why why are
they repressed sexually but how why
would you be repressing the marriage
because you're supposed to consummate
and consummate because you could be
brought up in a family where sex is very
taboo and as a woman you either you need
to be
more than pretty but i feel like even in
like say we take the catholic church or
islam once you get married you're
supposed to be chop chop chop chop
contraception so i don't really
understand that one yeah every day
the message is always like wait till
marriage i feel like it's not they're
not like don't have sex but it's also
like
don't be sexual outside of marriage and
if you grow up with someone saying like
cover yourself up oh don't put yourself
on display don't don't express yourself
in that way
we think all of a sudden when you're
married you're going to be like oh i'm
this wild
sensual woman no i think it could be
yeah
could i say nobody gets uh married
quicker than two horny muslims or two
because you wanna go and do the job that
you've been suppressed okay yeah i don't
think women are suppressed in society at
all i think we're actually rewarded for
being sexual i mean you get more
followers on instagram you get more dms
you get you can make money on only fans
and even when people try to shame women
and say hey that's that's hoe behavior
there there's they say slut-shaming so
they'll shame men for shaming women
okay so i don't really think women are
you know but then even if you are
in on instagram or being
whatever
you're slut-shamed or whatever you're
doing
just because someone is doing that to
you doesn't mean that you
are then more likely to get married
what do you mean so if you're very
promiscuous and open about it
are you going to be married that's true
you're correct probably women that tend
to be married perhaps are more
traditional
and would
hide their sexuality be a bit more
convert and and
portray this image of like
purity yes
yes
yeah
especially depends on the environment
that you're in as well your background
your culture everything has a factor on
that as well
yeah
i feel like that would also like that
kind of home training would also be
associated with being like submissive to
your husband
so then the sexual side would come into
it when he initiates it but that doesn't
mean you feel comfortable in your
sexuality he might want to go all the
time and you haven't learned to express
you are if it's the right guy you wanna
you won't have sex all the time every
girl has had a guy that she wants to
have sex all the time i mean that's the
one you marry no i know but that's the
point that's why that's why
like that's the whole point is because
because you're marrying yeah because
you're marrying the guy that you're not
that attracted to
and so like basically the more partners
a woman has the less likely she is to
have a happy marriage so if someone has
a bad boy past like she's less likely to
be satisfied in her marriage because if
you're a virgin when you get married you
have an 80 chance of getting into a
happy marriage after 10 years if you
have had sex with more than five people
which i think most men pray for
nowadays and
um
it drops down to 25
okay and so i think that's why
historically we've always protected
women and like tell them to like not be
sexual outside of marriage because the
bond like the bond is so strong for
women during sex we release a hormone
during sex that men don't
oxytocin yeah and the more you have sex
with people the less you release it's
like a defense mechanism basically yeah
that's interesting
and it all comes to that bondage you're
saying of uh the person that you
marry you might not actually be
satisfied satisfied with sexually
oxytocin is only released when you
actually come so if you're with a guy he
doesn't make you come you're not going
to have that bond
[Music]
if he doesn't get you there well why
would you let's say
you're not talking about anyone
but say why would you ever marry someone
like that because you're a virgin and
it's
well if you're a virgin if you're a
virgin you don't know different i hate
it so like how would you know the sex is
bad if you're a virgin
i hate that
and some girls don't have the option
like you can't have everything in a guy
so when do they realize that [ __ ] or did
they just go on thinking this [ __ ] their
whole life what do you well i think i
mean the average age of first marriage
in the uk is 31. yeah it makes sense so
you don't want to be a virgin really no
yeah so it's like those those girls i
mean they they've obviously if they
start having sex at 16
like one a year that's like at least 12
13 right yeah they've done a med team
yeah and so and so it's like
i mean you can't have everything and i
think when you time's running out you
got to pick what you want so some girls
are going to marry the guy they're not
attracted to but the problem is the guys
don't know that
because he thinks that
men are insecurities we always want
a woman that's
more attractive than us so we think oh
yeah we've hit the jackpot really and
truly you're like hers like 10th pick
100th pick where when that's your
primary number one and you've worked his
whole life like no one ever liked you
and you worked your whole life to become
an accountant and you got a qualified
accountant worked for ten years
and then you finally got someone sloppy
seconds and you're so happy but she's
sloppy at the end of the day